good morning John thank you for your
video Monday where you explained all the
ways in which the world has actually
gotten a lot better in the last 15 years
which would indicate that we have the
ability to make it even better in the
next 15 years there was a problem with
your video John it's that you made your
video about good news and we are
cognitively biased to be both
disinterested in and kind of skeptical
of good news especially when that good
news is so large-scale that we can't
really get emotionally involved in it
it's kind of difficult to care so I'm
gonna be taking a different tack job
today right now as 193 leaders
throughout the world sign on to the UN
global goals for the next 15 years I
don't care how much better things have
gotten because they still suck I don't
like outrage for outrages sake I don't
like the news getting me all riled up
about things they don't really matter
that much I want to be angry that
children are dying that gender
inequality exists pretty much everywhere
on earth that six million people will
die this year because they don't have
access to clean water the world is
messed up but we have a plan there are
17 global goals each with a number of
outline distinct targets that the UN is
asking every nation on earth to help us
all achieve by 2030 and you know what
the chances of us pulling that off are
if nobody cares about it zero absolutely
zero we basically need every person on
earth to know about these goals because
they are achievable and we can do this
but only if people hold their
governments accountable only if we care
so discover the joy with me
of being pissed off for a good reason
not an opposition of some other group of
people but an absolute agreement with
everybody on earth every child on earth
should go to school
no one should be hungry no one should be
in extreme poverty and corrupt
governments and greed should not stand
in the way of these goals and I don't
mean to be a doomsayer but it's not
gonna matter if we achieve these goals
if we build them on top of an
unsustainable exploitation of our planet
in order for this world to make the kind
of investments it needs to achieve these
goals we have to care we have to hold
our leaders accountable and if you do
care then you kind of definitionally
have to be angry because it's infuriate
to get angry soon as a global goal that
resonates the most with you draw that on
your face with some eyeliner or some
sharpie I don't care share with all your
people put it on your instagrams on your
snap caps and Facebook's I don't care
where you put it share it with the world
people have to know when I spit on you
oh I'm sorry that's so unfortunate for
you get up share the global goals
Brown poster head públicos org put it up
in your school campus area your office
or around your town and show it to your
mom share this with the rest of the
world because we have gone half way and
that is not far enough let it out with
me feel it with me scream that this
vector of injustice and unfairness and
then go to global goals org find out
what all the fuss is about pick your
favorite goal draw it on your face or
have a friend do it cuz I found out it's
actually quite hard to draw something on
your own face let people know what the
heck's going on why they should know
about this and why they maybe should be
a little angry and also a little
optimistic about the future of life here
on earth John I'll see you on Tuesday
I'm honestly amazed at how far we've
come and how much infant mortality has
decreased at how much education and
access to clean water has increased
there's a tremendous amount of good news
but I'm really not being like
tongue-in-cheek eNOS I'm actually like I
think that if we're gonna get angry
about anything this is the stuff to get
angry about and it's kind of hard
because it isn't like one thing and it
doesn't feel like oh that's so
frustrating that this one thing happened
it's big it's big and it's hard to get
your mind around and it's impossible to
believe that we can actually do stuff
about this but we can the key one exists
for a reason and the global goals are an
actual plan and I am really amazed by
them and really inspired by them and I
really do hope that you will be inspired
whoever this is watching will be
inspired to share this stuff with people
around you and in your - and and in your
communities yeah I'm angry and I yell at
you
I apologize for that was a little freaky
but I think that we can do this stuff
but only if we hold our leaders
accountable and if we really want it to
happen and of all the things I want to
happen most of the world the achievement
of the global goals is number one on the
list I will never be angry again if we
can just pull this off